did you ever in school like want to like
break an arm to like be like be like
everyone like
care you know what i mean
i wasn't that desperate for attention
because like everyone would like right
on the kids broken cast i was like i
want that i
want a rider mom can i break my phone
please
i think i think like whatever like if
there was a god he knew i wanted a break
so i've never broken a bone in my head
yeah yeah i've like done
disgusting [ __ ] that should have broken
there was a there was a time where
like yeah i would see the cast thing and
i'd be like that looks so
cool that's what i'm not what i'm saying
like i don't have to break a bone but
i want to have like another cast and i
remember like i
like was like climbing a tree yeah and i
fell off and i landed on my arm
just look at the cast yeah in the back
of my head i was like yes
see finally i just worded it wrongly
yeah yeah but i wasn't like willingly
like all right let me find the questions
yeah i wasn't trying to eat myself i i
was just like
it would be cool if i did break it and
then when i found out it was just like a
really bad bruise i was like that's not
cool
you can get a capsule it's just a bruise
i don't get anything from this yeah what
the hell yeah
yeah no because i i've never i've also
never broken a bone in my body and i
don't know the thought scares me now
because i i don't know what it feels
like you get
yeah yeah yeah because i see so many
people because you know
i went to a high school that was very
predominantly sports based right so
right
you know boys would be like breaking
like their wrists or like their ankles
their arms their legs what not like
constantly and every time i would ask
because i i don't know why i've never
broken a bone in my body either i would
always ask like does it hurt
and they're always just like ah no not
really and i'm just like
[ __ ] i've i've had splinters and
they [ __ ] hurt
of course that [ __ ] hurts what are
you talking about i mean there's people
who realize
that don't realize like their fingers
are broken or something at some points
like oh yeah yeah my school didn't
realize his finger was broken until like
it had set
like wonky like because he didn't go to
the hospital
and it just how do you not realize that
[ __ ] yeah
[Music]
it's like oh my finger kind of hurts
looks kind of weird too
90 degrees what's up with that and
meanwhile there's me i get a paper cut
i'm like
get the [ __ ] bandages can you see
bone can you see bone
like what get the alcohol quick
oh my god i'm too british i feel like if
my hand was like impaled
i'd be like no well i mean it's just a
flesh word
put a bit of sanitizer on it and i think
it should be fine